I haven't done anything yet but I don't
want the applause we've got some great
speakers my name is cliff kincaid I'm
president of America survival us a
survival org one quick note there's
going to be a slight change in the
program we're going to have a first
panel consisting of Jerry Kenny and his
attorney Jeff Timmons to discuss the FCC
complaint over the erring by public
television stations of al-jazeera and
Russia today television and then we will
take a quick break and go to Charles or
tell after that and the rest of the
program is as scheduled president Obama
has already lost Egypt by cheering on
the mobs and the demonstrators the same
crowd that assaulted CBS News
correspondent lara logan a story by the
way that was ignored by al-jazeera
except for a brief mention in a blog and
now our president is threatening to make
things worse by talking about possibly
arming the rebels in Libya who include
members of al-qaeda as somebody who
through America survival assisted the
families of the victims of the pan am
103 terrorist bombing and helped expose
the Clinton United Nations deal that let
Qaddafi personally
off the hook for that atrocity nobody
wants to see Qaddafi in the grave more
than I do but these rebels in Libya are
not as al Jazeera describes them quote
pro-democracy fighters at least not all
of them al Jazeera's agenda is clear to
target pro-western and secular regimes
in the Middle East and overturn them
enabling the Muslim Brotherhood to take
power can the situation get worse in
Libya as Sarah Palin might say you
betcha you betcha Qaddafi has been
targeted for death by none other than
use of Tara dowie the Muslim cleric who
has had a TV show on al Jazeera for many
many years indeed he's one of Al Jazeera
Arabic stars who usually rants and raves
about killing the Jews to Kara dolly
qaddafi who has since his turnaround
than actually assisting the United
States and finding members of al Qaeda
is quote on Islamic what is mystifying
to me is so many people even on the
conservative side who claimed not to
understand the Obama administration's
agenda but we find in the WikiLeaks
cables on al Jazeera and its sponsor and
funder the government of Qatar that Al
Jazeera has changed its coverage since
Obama became president to be more
sympathetic to the American government
which suggests that the American
government under Obama is on the side of
the global jihad this is not a big
surprise as we were the first to
disclose that one of alg azeras
correspondence Casey Kaufman
who actually covered the presidential
campaign here in 2008 himself
contributed $500 to the Obama for
president campaign even though
al-jazeera of course has an ethics code
did Al Jazeera know something about
Obama that many people didn't at the
time I think our keynote speaker later
Pamela Geller is going to have some
answers for us as someone who has
written a book getting to the heart of
what this Obama administration agenda
really is financial expert Charles or
tell we'll discuss the financial and
economic implications of the revolutions
the bloodshed in the chaos we see in the
Middle East and how that may impact us
here at home lee kaplan another one of
our speakers will discuss what's called
the International Solidarity movement
now including such notables as Bill
Ayers and bernadine dohrn Associates of
the President of the United States and
who are now showing up with regularity
in the Middle East we had tried
ourselves ladies and gentlemen back in
2008 through America survival to issue
warnings and tell the truth we had
obtained and had released to the 600
page FBI file on one Frank Marshall
Davis who was a president obama's
childhood mentor in Hawaii Davis who was
a member of the Communist Party we have
produced evidence in testimony tying
Bill Ayers and bernadine dohrn to the
1970 bombing murder of a San Francisco
Police Sergeant by the name of Brian V
McDonnell that's a case still open and
under investigation which is
nevertheless in jeopardy because of
obama's Attorney General Eric Holder
who we all remember I hope was interim
instrumental in the Clinton
administration pardons of members of The
Weather Underground headed of course by
errors and Dorne commentators and
pundits and the talking heads today talk
about this Arab Spring well the arab
spring has sprung they talk some of them
do well-respected commentators about the
islamic energy that's flowing through
the Middle East that's coursing through
the arab street these currents this
energy is based on the words and images
of Al Jazeera which reaches those Arabs
and Muslims a mouthpiece for terrorist
groups going back to Al Qaeda but
continuing through such groups as
Hezbollah and Hamas and more as the 1.2
billion dollar lawsuit against Al
Jazeera over facilitating the Hezbollah
rocket attacks on Israel suggests this
channel works hand in glove with the
enemy and in fact is openly described on
the Muslim Brotherhood website as quote
the great Arab media organization we
American taxpayers spend over 30 billion
dollars a year on intelligence on the
intelligence community and yet our top
officials pretend not to recognize
what's happening right in front of their
eyes we've got the case of Michael
Lichter the director of the National
Counterterrorism Center who's quoted in
one column earlier this week as saying
that Al Jazeera is his favorite
television station now this quote has
been disputed by his press operative I
talked to the press operative he didn't
really say that
we're told he only said that he thought
out is here as coverage of the events in
Egypt was pretty good but what is there
to praise as our first speaker Jerry
Kenny has pointed out al Jazeera's
rolled in Egypt and other countries is
like an arsonist first on the scene of a
fire telling everybody she's coming in
later to give him credit for the
photographs and the film footage of the
blazing Inferno this rationale is absurd
and bizarre as it is is what is
convincing American media commentators
like Sam Donaldson on a national network
news program to actually thank al
Jazeera for its coverage of the Middle
East this is the argument that's being
used to convince cable and satellite
providers in the United States to give
more courage give more distribution
rights to Al Jazeera English in the
United States the irony is that the
channel is already available on 30
public TV stations around the country
meaning that American taxpayers are
helping to put right now at this time
jihad TV on the air not only through the
tax dollars provided a public TV but
through the tax dollars provided to mhz
networks the distributor which is a
division of commonwealth public
broadcasting itself a recipient of over
two million dollars a year in federal
and state funds that arrangement also
includes Russia Today television
Vladimir Putin's channel which has been
attempting to boost its viewership by
running ads featuring Joseph Stalin and
which like Al Jazeera has been running
stories about how the 911 terrorist
attacks on american soil were an inside
job the WikiLeaks cables demonstrate
that al Jazeera's funder and backer is
not a friend of the United States and
that the government of Qatar has been
protecting terrorists including the
mastermind of 911 Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
and other 911 plotters one cable says
who may still even today beyond the
loose it was the Israeli intelligence
chief and one of these cables who had
predicted that al Jazeera would spark
the next war in the Middle East and it's
coming dr. Judea pearl told me in a
statement that we have provided in a
statement he gave to me exclusively for
this conference that al Jazeera still
remains the greatest recruiter for
terrorism in the world today and in fact
has hardened it's anti-american
anti-western bias he says al jazeera
english should be resisted because of
the potential for inspiring homegrown
jihadism on american soil we know
because the captured terrorists told us
so that the words and images of Al
Jazeera had inspired them to go to Iraq
to kill Americans and so as a result we
are asking Congressman Peter King
chairman of the House Homeland Security
Committee to open hearings on and
investigate the threat posed by Al
Jazeera at home and abroad through
America survival we will launch a
petition campaign asking the American
people to make expressions of support
that we will provide a representative
peter king showing grassroots support
for such a probe we know that the killer
of dr. pearls son Daniel Pearl The Wall
Street Journal reporter the killer was
the same 9-11 mastermind Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed
who was protected by the regime and
cutter you don't have to read the
WikiLeaks cables to know that that's a
matter of public record even the 911
Commission recognized that fact but now
we see in connection with Libya the
government of Qatar providing aircraft
for the mission depicted by our media as
a pro-american measure even though the
Qatar foreign minister makes it plain
that the regime's intervention should
not be misinterpreted he says as being
against Colonel Qaddafi or his sons this
is the same garbage we have been getting
from this corrupt monarchy for years as
the Israeli intelligence chief says in
WikiLeaks Qatar is trying to be on all
sides of the issue pretending to be
pro-american while funding Hamas and
Hizballah hosting an American base while
refusing to crack down on anti American
terrorists inside its borders this con
jobs exceeds because the regime spends
lavishly on American politicians and
congressional staffers to go on junkets
to Qatar and through aljazeera pays the
way for journalists and academics to
live it up at the recent algae reform
al-jazeera forum in doha qatar at the
opulent Sheraton with a private beach a
view of the sea and private gardens
journalists guests of the regime
al-jazeera must be resisted and exposed
and the regime that pays its bills and
protects and funds terrorists should be
added to the official list of state
sponsors of terrorism to Comcast and
other cable & satellite providers we say
do not expand al-jazeera throughout the
United States
otherwise you will increase the chances
of Americans being killed by those
manipulated by jihad TV the terror
network and you comcast will have blood
on your hands I repeat we asked
Congressman Peter King to investigate al
Jazeera as a global terrorist entity in
the same way that Hezbollah's TV station
al-manar was examined and its distribute
distributors prosecuted convicted and
sentenced in that case the programming
was in fact banned in the United States
Comcast pay attention to the 1.2 billion
dollar lawsuit against Al Jazeera in the
Southern District of New York asking
again 1.2 billion dollars in damages for
the victims and the families of the
victims of the Hezbollah rocket attacks
in Israel facilitated by the terror
Channel and those victims were Israeli
Canadian and American we believe al
Jazeera ought to be investigated for
violating the law against providing
support to foreign terrorist
organizations let's have congressional
hearings into al Jazeera and for that
matter Russia today and even Iranian
press TV also operating on American soil
these are not news organizations their
instruments of authoritarian or
dictatorial regimes just as it would
have been insane to give Tokyo Rose
access to the American airwaves during
World War two it constitutes the suicide
of the West to accommodate al Jazeera's
campaign to destroy the West through
violence and terrorism they must be
exposed they must be stopped ladies and
gentlemen it's a privilege and honor for
me to introduce our next speaker
Jerry Kenny is an independent television
producer from Florida a graduate of
Daytona State College and he came to my
attention because he uncovered the
illegal relationship of mhz networks a
division of commonwealth public
broadcasting with around 30 public TV
stations around the country whereby
these stations have basically turned
over some of their airwaves their
channels to al-jazeera and russia today
television jerry subsequently hired a
lawyer jeff timmons who will speak after
him to file a complaint with the Federal
Communications Commission arguing that
these contracts these relationships of
violate FCC rules Jerry Kenny thank you
I'm not accustomed to addressing a group
like this so I really don't have any
prepared comments today but I would like
to I guess start by telling you that I
guess several months back I was at home
in daytona beach florida watching
television and i was surfing up around i
think channel 20,000 and 89 or something
and then goes around 11 11-50 and saw
the words al Jazeera and it happened to
be a subchannel for my public television
station that is operated owned and
operated by the local college and did a
little bit of research and the more I
found the the the more disturbed i
became and put together what what we
have pretty much in the complaint that
you can pick up a copy of but I I put
together a complete dossier if you will
of internal memos that were within
within the television station itself
that showed some pretty disturbing
things for example that the that the
station received a complaint from a
soldier who had just gotten back from
deployment and he was upset about the
fact in this email that he was watching
al-jazeera on television and complained
to the station
program director and in one of her
internal emails back and forth she said
that can't be we don't have al Jazeera
on our station I'm paraphrasing it but
she did a little bit of research in
golly she found out they were actually
airing al Jazeera and they'd been doing
so for several months and then some of
the emails kind of went a little bit as
to describe how the staff was supposed
to deal with this soldier when he called
in and I think at one point she the the
soldier was referred to as being faint
of brain or at least the people that
would complain about Al Jazeera being on
a tax supported television station so
anyway I put this whole thing together
as best as I could and laid it out and I
looked at the federal law and I
contacted a local newspaper reporter
thinking that hey this this is a
Pulitzer Prize you know that we've got
coming here this is a heck of a story
and I called her up and I said hey I
said I've got an unbelievable story al
Jazeera is on public television and she
said okay and I said al Jazeera
tax-supported public television she said
yeah okay all right I said al Jazeera
she said well well he's a jazz singer
isn't he ok so I knew we were going to
have some problems especially with
dealing with the press but there seems
to be an awful lot of misunderstanding
as to to what al Jazeera is I guess it's
easier if you say what rather than who
if you say who they they it's kind of
hard to find the difference between Al
Jazeera I think Al Jolson and it would
be al jarreau I guess would be the other
one but America needs to do its homework
and I blame in part the press I really
do there's a lot of money a lot of Petro
dollars that are floating around this
country and it just seems that that
greece's the wheel and it's absolutely
amazing and in academia I'm absolutely
ashamed of the school that I went to I'm
ashamed of them that the part of their
philosophy is that this is freedom of
press that's
I was told by the by the president of
the school well with this is a freedom
of speech issue no this is free airtime
issue and actually it's not free airtime
ok someone is paying for the airtime and
the person that's paying for the air
time to put al Jazeera on the air are
the taxpayers of this country now i find
that unconscionable i I really do so
anyway as I said it's rather clear I
didn't have prepared comments today but
I did file a complaint with the FCC and
it has to do with the fact that the
station originally did not sign an
agreement with the distributor of Al
Jazeera that gave the station the
opportunity to reject any programming
because that was the first thing we were
told by the station management oh we
can't reject this programming we've got
a signed contract here that says we
cannot reject it now if you're a
propagandist I can't think of a more
perfect situation where you're getting
free airtime and you cannot edit that
air time it's it's it's unbelievable and
and then the other thing is that I
believe is the they turn control of that
station of that subchannel over to a
third party without FCC approval and
that that's pretty much a no-no but
anyway that's that's the essence of it
it's it's in the way I think we have a
copy of it here and would I guess if you
could hear from I'll turn it back to you
okay sir thank you very
to think about the madness here of
American taxpayers through the public TV
stations and NHC networks of
Commonwealth public broadcasting paying
to put Al Jazeera and Russia Today TV on
the air when the guy who runs al Jazeera
Arabic and English the Emir of Qatar His
Highness is worth according to the
latest forbes magazine list of richest
Royals 2.4 billion personally 2.4
billion dollars he he has a 436 foot
superyacht one of the world's largest in
fact i think i went to the super yachts
com it's number 10 on the list worldwide
2.4 billion dollars and yet we're paying
him basically to put his channel on the
air here attorney jeff timmons has
practiced communications law since 1993
is initially with a firm in washington
DC before the past decade has been a
solo practitioner primarily advising
mass media clients he concentrates on
regulatory compliance and licensing
matters before the FCC he's a graduate
of Johns Hopkins University and a
graduate of the Catholic University of
America columbus school of law counselor
Thank You cliff unlike Jerry I do have
some prepared remarks but unfortunately
a problem will be as fluid in the
delivery as he was without prepared
remarks but as mentioned I'm a
communications lawyer that's that's all
I do is represent usually radio station
and TV station broadcasters before the
FCC and when Jerry Kenny first
approached me about the mega mega Hertz
networks al Jazeera English in Russia
today programming being aired on his
local public television station WDS see
down in the Daytona Beach market Myron
initial reaction was that the station
can air whatever program it wanted the
broadcast station licensees they have a
First Amendment right to air whatever
program that they believe will serve the
public interest well caught my interest
was in looking at the documentation was
that in responding to the public
inquiries first from the soldier Staff
Sergeant Richard Bettis and then from
mr. kenny was that they tried to pass
off their responsibility to maintain
control of their programming based on
the terms of their affiliation agreement
with megahertz networks you know after
refusing the affiliation agreement the
correspondence it became clear that the
station w DSC had abdicated its control
over the programming in a manner that
violated the FCC's rules and policies so
I agreed to file the complaint for Jerry
the specifics of the complaint focused
on two fairly narrow issues the first
was a violation of section 73 650 aee of
the FCC's rules which requires licensees
to retain the right in their affiliation
or program agreements to reject
programming that they find
unsatisfactory or unsuitable or contrary
to the public interest and secondarily
section 73 35 40 of the FCC's rules
which prohibits a transfer of control of
a station without prior FCC can
sat where the three traditional indicia
of control at the FCC that the SEC
considers our programming personnel and
finances and clear that this is one of
the three main areas that the FCC would
evaluate as far as control of the
station the latter issue about the
control of the station and the control
of the programming was raised by the
documentation that Jerry found in his
investigation and public records request
where the programming manager of the
station essentially stated that she was
not aware that the station was even
airing the Al Jazeera English or Russia
Today programming on the station at the
time that she received the complaints
from staff sergeants vettes to be clear
what the complaint did not do did not
ask the FCC to require the station take
the programming off the air if you the
response that we initially got from the
station and from megahertz networks
their response megahertz networks
actually sent out correspondence to each
of its stations warning them that Jerry
may be contacting them to ask for copies
of affiliation agreements suggestions
they not cooperate with him one of the
points they made was that they and
particularly the licensee of the station
Daytona State College when the point
they made was that it be censorship for
for the station to not air the the
program's as good as they find it
objectionable and the point of course
doesn't ask the FCC to censor the FCC is
precluded by statute from doing that
section 326 the Communications Act
prohibits them gives them no power of
censorship and may not interfere with
the right of free speech of broadcasters
so to the extent the station or
megahertz networks try to claim that
this is an imposition on the First
Amendment rights was essentially a red
herring and nothing could be further
from the truth in fact with the the
opposition from people such as mr.
Kenney and staff sergeant Bettis
demonstrates how the First Amendment's
are truly work which is an open
discussion the marketplace of ideas
concept that was inspired Thomas
Jefferson our founding fathers to
include the first amendment in the Bill
of Rights megahertz network of course
has a first moment right to produce its
programming and to just try to
disseminate it however it wishes but it
doesn't give them a right to have it
aired on any specific station and
certainly not on a taxpayer-funded
public television station I think anyone
in this room knows that no one has a
specific right to have their views put
out over a station I know I don't you
don't Mr Kenny doesn't have a right to
go to a station and say you must dare my
programming that right doesn't exist if
it did I would want to know when my hour
of air time would be Daytona State
College as the licensee of the TV
station of course has the First
Amendment right to air whatever it
chooses over the station but it doesn't
shield them from public opinion or
criticism of their choices by quite the
opposite Mr Kenny and staff sergeant
Bettis were doing their exercising their
First Amendment rights to object to the
programming and try to get it changed
and in fact that's the type of public
discourse that the the FCC rule involves
section 73 6650 80 is directed toward
it's directed toward ensuring that the
licensee of the broadcast station who
has the obligation as a licensee as a
public trustee to air program at the
service of Public Interest that
provision the FCC rules requires them to
have retaining their affiliation or
program agreements this right to reject
programming for that very reason so that
they can exercise and their First
Amendment rights and protect the advance
of Public Interest when they
err their programming and if I can make
an additional point which sort of goes
beyond the scope of the complaint the
broader issue as as Jerry mentioned is
not just that this program being aired
on a public station but it's it not just
being aired on a television station it
was being aired on a publix television
station that was funded by you and I and
other US taxpayers money so in closing
if if megahertz networks wishes to air
this al Jazeera English and Russia today
programming it's free to do so but it
should find an outlet other than a
taxpayer-funded public television
station we have available to you a
printed copy of a foot 149 page
powerpoint presentation that includes a
lot of the background and key documents
surrounding what we are talking about
today these documents show that MHC
megahertz networks has been getting over
two million a year in one particular
year over three million a year from
federal and state sources we also have
some examples of some other MHC network
of programming it is I repeat a division
of Commonwealth public broadcasting
which is defined under the law as a
public supported charity exempt from
federal income tax and we're going to we
have enough time we're actually ahead of
schedule we're going to open it up to
some questions for Jerry and Jeff about
this matter but before we do is Clifford
here
if you if you want to ask a question
raise your hand raise your hand let me
make a critical point we have some
material in our PowerPoint presentation
and rest assured i'm not going to go
through 149 slides of a PowerPoint up
here anybody want me to know you can
look at them for yourself but what we've
done I think through this a presentation
is give you the key background the
documents some examples of the the
programs and stories were getting from
Al Jazeera as well as Russia Today
television plus there's an interesting
section near the end there about why our
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton would
talk about Al Jazeera providing quote
real news when we discover that the
government of Qatar funding al Jazeera
has been very generous shall we put it
shall we say to Bill Clinton himself
through his foundation and through
bringing him to cut her on numerous
occasions to preside over for example
the opening in Qatar of a
sharia-compliant bank so this was an
issue that came up when Hillary Clinton
was first proposed as Secretary of State
whether her relationship with her
husband and his many financial
relationships would compromise
compromise her ability to do her job but
in fairness I should say this when it
comes to quote real news and this is
from the Hillary Clinton's own State
Department human rights report now this
is important to hear because we hear
over and over again that al Jazeera is
really independent and it
as editorial integrity and even though
the Emir his highness worth 2.4 billion
dollars with a 396 foot yacht pays the
bills that he really has no control over
the the product or the personnel
accepted here's from the US State
Department human rights report quote al
Jazeera and the government claimed that
the channel was independent and free of
government influence but the government
exercised editorial and programmatic
control of the channel through funding
and selection of the station's
management case closed calorie you ought
to read your own State Department report
any questions or comments for our
panelists yes sir cliff I have a
question for you you mentioned here that
you met with congressman pete King and
filled Green Gingrey I'd like to know
how that conversation went how what kind
of response did you get out of them are
well what impression did you come away
with the purpose of that meeting was to
primarily express support for
congressman King and his hearings into
radicalism this was before the first
so-called controversial hearing recently
we support congressman King we support
his hearings we want to see more of
these hearings faster and we think they
ought to be expanded and so I was able
to present one of our reports to him on
events in the Middle East and mentioned
and this was included in the report that
al-jazeera should be examined should we
looked at during the course of these
hearings he was not specific in terms of
committing to any hearing on that
particular matter but I know
he's committed to follow through and
he's not intimidated by all of the
attacks on him one of the reasons I ask
the questions cliff is because some
people have criticized him not
withstanding the battering he took from
the left wing members of his committee
during that hearing but he actually did
not and does not show signs of going far
enough with this investigation I think
he has his own approach he's going at it
in a systematic way we all some of us
may think that he ought to proceed at a
quicker pace but I'm willing to give him
the benefit of the doubt and I I support
these hearings i might add though that
if these hearings failed to produce what
we think should happen we think the
congress at least a house ought to
consider the reestablishing another
committee or subcommittee perhaps
dealing with internal security matters
to carry on those investigations if i
may just interject your one little thing
on that latter point it is my
understanding that the Republican
Conference behind closed door has had a
long conversation on that very proposal
and discarded it I have no idea what
kind of weapon where the conversation
went or who participated we at our last
conference in this room as you remember
in October of last year had a variety of
experts calling for the reestablishment
of committees or sub committees in both
houses of Congress to look at internal
security problems and threats we
received some support for that
investigative reporter Jim Simpson
interviewed congressman steve king who
said he was in favor of such an approach
establishing such a committee or
subcommittee I don't know what happened
behind closed doors but that's part of
why we're here today is to increase
public support for the Congress to do
its job we've got enemies of the United
States active on American soil using
foreign propaganda through public TV
against our very existence and survival
it's an outrage it has to stop Congress
has to do its job go ahead right here
and then we'll get back to you I realize
that you'll quite properly focused on
your station called there I'm wondering
how if you all haven't got any how broad
this is how many other stations there
are who is this company the negev hurts
networks are they a complicit in
focusing on this type of thing and I'm
also wondering if I've hurt I hear that
websites of Russian web TV or Russian
websites in Russian very and content
quite a bit from the English so Pope so
called translation versions of the same
supposedly same websites and the same
thing with with ones in Arabic that the
if you actually translate the Arabic
it's very different from the message
that is given on the English version
although in theory the English version
is a translation when really it's not
it's a different slant and I'm wondering
if you all have any information about
that with regard to what
station in fart I can handle the ladder
but if you can talk about first whether
there's any indication of any other
stations than part of this arrangement
well that the the megahertz feed goes to
30 public educational stations right now
the thing that I thought was interesting
as I got into this was that I basically
sent an email to those stations to see
if they had an affiliate agreement that
essentially turned control of the
station over to the foreign propaganda
sore megahertz network or whatever and I
was just amazed that a letter was
delivered by this belief at that time he
was the CEO of the network warning them
that this little guy Gerry Kenny from
Daytona Beach Florida was going to be
contacting you and asking you for a copy
of your affiliate agreement now if that
doesn't get your attention you're just
not paying attention but so that i know
that it's on the 30 stations and if it
were on one you know it wouldn't matter
but it's it's out there it's out there
and from the the legal side the
complaint was filed only against the one
station in daytona the daytona area
because that's the one station where we
had the documents in the personal
knowledge when you file a complaint you
have to see you have to include an
affidavit with someone a personal
knowledge of the facts that you're
presenting to them but in the complaint
we did point out to the FCC that there
are a little over 30 other stations
around the country that were affiliates
of the same of megahertz networks that
likely had the very same affiliation
agreements I mean they don't draft
individual affiliation agreements for
each different station for the most part
they start with a standard form and they
make few small modifications so we asked
that we gave a list of all those
stations and if you pick up a copy of
the complaint that's one of the exhibits
at the back has a list of the 30
stations we asked the FCC on its own
motion to look at the affiliation
agreements for all these other stations
other than WDS see down at Daytona to
see if that provision is in the prep in
the affiliation agreement for the other
stations or not and actually it too if
any of these stations are in your market
and you want to raise the profile of the
issue
certainly file additional complaints if
anyone checks out their own station
bonds the affiliation agreement the
station should have a copy of that
agreement in their local public
inspection file you should be able to
walk into their main studio and ask to
see the local public inspection file and
find a copy of that affiliation
agreement and if it's a public or a
college or a government agency there's
probably a public records request that
you could go through to request a copy
of the affiliation agreement let me add
on that latter point or question about
the differences between the English or
Arabic websites or channels please take
a look at dr. Judea pearl statement
because he gets to the heart of this
Sheikh heradao e is a fixture on al
Jazeera Arabic he's the Jew hater his
statements and these have been made on
al Jazeera Arabic January 2009 o Allah
count their numbers referring to the
Jews and kill them down to the very last
one now there's many more statements
like that kara dolly was based in Qatar
she's now returned to Egypt where he
told his followers that they intend to
conquer Jerusalem kara duhe we have a
picture in our report obviously was very
close to the Emir his Highness of Qatar
Kara dolly is on al Jazeera Arabic but
those behind the channel are smart
enough not to put him on al Jazeera
English they do water down the English
content somewhat to make it quote less
offensive although they still go off
into these crazy tangents about the 911
inside job theory and and other material
like that
dr. pearls statement is very important
on this point because he says the
following I am deeply concerned he's
talking about accepting al jazeera
english i am deeply concerned about the
consequences of further empowering al
Jazeera's management with acceptance
which would reinforce their illusion
that we are blind to their aims and
tactics any more questions Oh way in the
back there please
cliff thanks for having the courage to
do what you're doing today um I wanted
to ask you as you're aware care and
other Islamist organizations have been
very active in getting conservatives and
anti Sharia commentators removed such as
Fred Grandy here on wmal are they doing
this in Reverse now where they're trying
to get pro shriya you know al jazeera
people on TV and expand their message
here in the united states do you think
care or any of the Hamas Muslim
Brotherhood fronts are involved in
promoting this well they're all part of
the same mix remember al Jazeera
promotes Hamas has been implicated in
the Hezbollah war on Israel got its
notoriety in the beginning as abouth
piece for al-qaeda in addition it's been
a mouthpiece for groups like the Islamic
army of Iraq which is still active
killing Americans there so the
relationship is very close don't forget
that of course and we have this in our
report all of this is available at us a
survival org to our website and we've
been covering this extensively an Al
Jazeera correspondent one of those who
interviewed bin Laden for Al Jazeera in
the beginning back in Afghanistan was
actually prosecuted convicted and
sentenced to prison in Spain for being
an agent a financial carrier for al
Qaeda his name was tastier Looney
sentenced to prison in Spain for being
an agent of al Qaeda so the relationship
between the terrorist movement in
Algeria al Jazeera is like hand and
glove they functioned together and
that's why you find for example the
Muslim Brotherhood website promoting al
Jazeera as the great Arab media
organization and then in return you find
al Jazeera promoting the Muslim
Brotherhood any other questions lately
yeah I just want to say that if you go
to I've got a plug in for my website if
I can to Kenny tv.com I have the
internal emails from WDS CTV where
they're discussing this issue back and
forth and when they were confronted by
this soldier who objected to Al Jazeera
and you can see that it was very closely
coordinated with the PR firm for Al
Jazeera that they were using all of
their talking points but what was
interesting after in these emails on
Kenny TV ok after after the program
director finally saw one episode of
al-jazeera she concluded that it was
innocuous and and she said and and I you
know as I say I think it probably was
the you know the $1,500 suits or the
British accents the proper British
accents but what people need to
understand is this is propaganda folks
ok I don't speak Arabic if they want to
reach the the American public they're
going to have to walk and talk like
something that we relate to Tokyo Rose
was an American you know anyway that's
had to get that in there I don't know
who was up next time back there Jim and
then we'll come back over here you're
moving in the direction that I was
hoping you know during World War 2 the
British would broadcast music and
messages over the air to agents in
occupied France and I wonder if Al
Jazeera also acts as a conduit like that
too sleeper agents in this country or is
it strictly a propaganda thing that is a
subject that ought to be examined and
the subject of hearings we know
according to the hearings that were
conducted on the Senate side by the
senate homeland secure
committee that clearly the internet is
being used to reach the homegrown
jihadis here the terrorists in Yemen al
Malaki was involved as we know in the
Fort Hood massacre and was in contact
with the Christmas Day bomber that's the
open question is what will the damage be
if we let al jazeera english get more
carriage in the united states and reach
these Arabs and Muslims here who don't
speak Arabic but want the
english-language message somewhat
watered down but not too much what kind
of messages are they going to receive
what will be the result will it be the
same as the kind of hate and incitement
and provocation that they could get
through the internet and before Comcast
and other cable & satellite systems make
that move they better understand the
ramifications of what they're doing
because they will have blood on their
hands so let's investigate this record
let's find out what's happening how
they're being motivated and what role al
Jazeera is playing well I yeah and the
the propaganda value to them is
immeasurable and the influence operation
opportunity for them is immeasurable but
I also wonder if there isn't a secondary
underground sort of military application
similar to what you know every country
in the world has done in times past and
probably even today in passing coded
messages to people who they know I don't
know the extent to which they how close
their relationship is with Muslim
Brotherhood and the other jihadist
organizations that have have sleeper
agents here as we know and have overt
agents here as we know but I think
that's it that's a interesting question
and you also raised the
shoo the gentleman up front raised the
issue about the stomach for hearings in
Internal Security Committee and the
rumor was that somebody killed it i
don't know about that but i do know from
my sources that the pressure is all come
from the leadership there's a lot of
people in Congress that would like to
see the kind of things that we would
like to see but the pressure to resist
that well we hope the leadership will
look at what we have on our website
videos youtube videos of this conference
are being made and will be posted we are
just trying to get out the facts the
documentation about the damage that this
network has already done to American
interests around the world why compound
the damage why increase the chances of
more homegrown terrorism in the United
States and I return again to the to the
statement of dr. Pearle this is what he
says in his statement regarding the
prospect of allowing al jazeera english
channel to broadcast in the US i wrote
and this is he's referring to something
he wrote previously with the growing
number of social misfits and society and
the growing confusion between
information and deception in the news
media the danger of fueling combustible
anger and some viewers cannot be ignored
especially when pumped subliminally by
well-respected western anchors and he
goes on considering our current concern
over the increase of homes home grown
terrorism incidents this danger is not
to be taken lightly and i would only add
in terms of these Western faces that you
allude to Jerry I remember years ago
debating Dave marish formerly of ABC
news when he was hired by al jazeera
english and he said oh we're going to be
independent and we're going to present
the news objectively and what happens a
few years later he quits citing the
channels anti-american bias one final
question then we'll take a quick break
did you have a question man
I'd like to know if if already there is
a station transmitting in Arabic because
for the last three or four years I have
been checking craig's list and there
have never been announcement for
requiring people speaking being fluent
in Arabic and but during the last six
months I have seen several job offers
for arabic speaking people for producers
for TV for announcers and all kinds of
positions so I would like to know if
there is anything already I don't know
to be honest with you gentlemen do you
have any comment on that all I can talk
about is the job openings that are
apparent with the English al-jazeera if
you watch it as I do occasionally
because we know want to know what the
enemy is up to you notice who their new
White House correspondent is lady named
patty Culhane where did she come from
MSNBC I think frankly some of the
support for Al Jazeera English is coming
from members of the news media here who
want to get jobs I mean this guy his
highness if anybody has deep pockets he
does I don't know what they're paying
over at Al Jazeera Arabic or aljazeera
english but I betcha it's pretty good
and I think some of them want that those
Petro dollars so some people will sell
out for money ladies and gentlemen we're
going to take a quick break about five
or so minutes and then we'll get to
Charles or tell so take a break have
some refreshments some sandwiches thank
you for coming we've got a lot more on
the agenda
the examiner come but now we have
hi